Danny Crawford our lead official 30
second season and he puts it up and
it'll be Teague and the Pacers who
controls he and t also Toronto and
Milwaukee on NBA TV as these terrific
players continue and they're on cue is
the second year man from Texas Myles
Turner who gets Indiana started
Cleveland winning Game one by one point
that almost that near miss my CJ my
house is Kyrie Irving gets the scoring
started for the Cavaliers
Cleveland's playing with a lot of
confidence on the offensive end
there's mouths turn open again Paul
George finds young and pad young in the
box score early game to LeBron didn't
even shoot for the first 10 minutes of
the first quarter as he dishes to Kevin
Love that something LeBron has been
doing so well is such a hard as he made
that look so easy that is unbelievable
what a big part of the Cavs offense
nearly 40% of their offense coming from
behind the arc young
two opportunities and the Pacers trying
to extend an eight-oh run
Cleveland's missed the last six
[Applause]
Robinson swings it now Stevenson inside
[Applause]
he's passed by Stephenson though setting
up therapy for a nice little 4 5 foot
jump hook here's LeBron James and he is
fouled chance at a three-point
possession for LeBron the offense of
blasting Cleveland coaching the
nine-minute mark of this first half
LeBron James for three got it his Turner
just back in gets his own board going
strong
[Music]
George you get to on the ball guides in
the middle of court and it's bad young
could have turned around he was hit all
my goodness the pass from Stephen
Simmons take you back to the lob out of
bounds Kevin yeah
LeBron is on top trying to force Paul
George backdoor let's five and a half to
go on this first half and Paul George
will pull on the pride and he hits and
he's got that mojo going along with
seven rebounds he has four assists as
well
whose plan Pig too strong and there is
young with the offensive board and a
pass that George couldn't handle and
back on the other end
Irving strong off the window let's got
to get one a quick top and now it
offensive board by young that is George
[Applause]
NBA he said what has to happen here as
we see the Pacers right now collapse
defensively not getting it there as JR
Smith not to downturn here at home this
year than they were on the road this
season that is holding true in their
first home game Kyrie Irving kicks it
out LeBron all the way across court love
for three here come the Cavs heck of a
play by loves and now James open for
three in the corner is marching pianist
core 36 in the first quarter 74 in the
first half all-time record nice pass
LeBron James sets up Tristan Thompson
perfectly look at the low reverse layup
Paul George pushing a triple-double he
got a double-double already young
followed by Thompson Wow flying high and
throws it down CJ Miles keeps it up and
it's blocked by Thompson right there
behind up Stephenson trying to find
George wayward Pass and a LeBron James
passes up two three goes all the way in
and scores with the finger roll off the
window lose go ahead and last and pull
the trigger they're double-teaming the
pick-and-roll long-range three by the
part
and a smile on his face you know deep he
is Brian if he is seven feet behind the
three-point line as he knocked it down
it gives a little wink to the fans after
his monster second quarter and I'm sure
he's glad to see one go through Kevin
dad no flexing tough tough shot again
too long to there by chanting fry but
second half and they're playing way too
late in the clock as a nice ball
movement there by Cleveland get it over
to the Chuck shooter quarter in the
corner he knocks it down 19 in the first
quarter a toe run by the Cavs Indiana
needing a basket desperately to give
them a lift is hoping so it's been an
incredible run by the Cavs and James
goes right five danyoung scores an
easily two point ballgame here to start
absolutely the news in this one that
Ernie gives you kid bit you need this is
gonna be a hammer LeBron just softly
lays it in
to the break way this was the first the
soft layin by James Paul George a chance
at triple-doubles together here 1020
Levon Shepard here's LeBron James
he's got Korver on the wing and taking
it
[Applause]
the next one after a great defensive
play gets it up I thought you did a good
quarter in the quarter and that's gonna
be a photograph for all time
[Applause]
adding fry I mean heat is right now got
to his game and he's by the throat
here's Paul George now unreal watch
watch for Korver coming to that left
corner here off the three and it's
LeBron who got the inbounds pass that
was easy and a lot easier than Nate
McMillan wanted to see under a moment
ago just it was a fantastic play drawn
up everybody cleared on LeBron wants it
back
young and James and a three points move
it well Smith with Teague on of shot
clock down to six
here's Smith on the take he whips it out
to the wing for the Cavs
what a possession by Cleveland EC Smith
breaks down the defense they come in to
help
leaving Channing Frye all alone knocks
it down let's see if Indiana consumer
way back in here Paul George for three
no fly is CJ Miles alright already Thank
You 17.6 quit three-quarter is up and
Claude
DJ miles hits a three got the start here
tonight yeah used triple picks coming
out of the right corner